[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Hello, everyone.
Today we'll talk
about doping, which
is the process of
intentionally adding impurities
to a semiconductor
in order to change
its electrical properties.
Doping is a critical
process in the tech world.
It's used in manufacturing
almost all semiconductor
technologies today.
Without doping, the solar
industry would not exist,
but even though doping
is common today,
the effects of impurities
confused semiconductor
physicists in the 1950s, who
had trouble reproducing results.
Eventually, they realized
that contamination levels,
as low as 1 in a
billion, were vastly
changing the electrical
properties of their samples.
Today, we'll show
you how this works
with a very simple experiment.
We'll be measuring the
electrical conductivity
of two silicon slabs
using an ohmmeter.
One is doped with impurities,
phosphorus in our case,
and the other is ultra-pure,
or what we call intrinsic.
Let's go over our experiment.
We'll start with
a slab of silicon,
which we attach
metal contacts to.
We'll use an ohmmeter,
that we connect
to our sample with metal wires
to measure the conductivity.
The conductivity
describes how well
electricity can flow
through the material.
The measured resistance
from our ohmmeter
is related to the inverse
of the conductivity.
The resistance also varies
according to the physical size
and shape of our
sample, which adds
a length over area term
to our equation, like so.
Rearranging this equation,
gives is what we're looking for,
the conductivity.
Let's measure our samples,
and estimate the conductivity.
Here are two samples, notice
that the doped sample looks
identical to the intrinsic
one, or undoped sample.
Because we've only
added trace impurities,
the optical
properties are nearly
identical between
the two samples.
Let's hook up the ohmmeter
to the intrinsic sample.
We can see that the resistance
is 130,000 ohms, which roughly
corresponds to a conductivity of
0.0002 inverse ohm centimeters.
Let's compare this
to the doped sample.
We read a resistance
of 34 ohms, which
corresponds to roughly 0.6
inverse ohm centimeters.
So we can see that the dope
sample is around 3,000 times
more conductive.
But why would
adding small amount
of our doping,
about one phosphorus
atom for every
million silicon atoms,
make our sample 3,000
times more conductive?
On the periodic table,
we see that silicon
is in the fourth
column, which means
it has four valence electrons.
Phosphorus, which is just
to the right in column five,
has five valence electrons,
one extra compared to silicon.
I'd also like to point
out boron in column three,
with one fewer valence
electron than silicon.
Later, I'll explain what happens
when you add boron as a dopant.
We'll start with a
2D representation
of a single silicon atom, with
the nucleus in the center,
and its four valence electrons
in a silicon crystal,
each silicon atom bonds to four
other silicon atoms around it.
These rigid covalent
bonds, shown here,
keep all of the electrons
effectively immobile, and are
therefore, unable to aid
in the full electricity.
Our intrinsic silicon,
or undoped example,
has this material
structure, which
is why it has a very
low conductivity.
Let's quantify this relationship
between conductivity and mobile
electrons.
Conductivity is defined
as n times mu times e.
n is a number of free
or mobile electrons.
Again, in this drawing
of intrinsic silicon,
all electrons are
covalently bonded so there
are no mobile
electrons, and n is 0.
The symbol mu represents the
mobility, a material parameter
which you can look up in
a textbook, or online,
and it basically describes how
well the charge can move around
in the material.
e is simply the amount of
charge that each mobile particle
possesses, which in
all of our cases,
is simply the charge
of an electron.
So let's ask, what happens when
we add dopants like phosphorus
and boron to the
silicon lattice?
Now, let's dope our material
by replacing one of the silicon
atoms with a phosphorus atom.
First, we'll remove
a silicon atom,
and for contrast, we'll dim
the background silicon lattice
so we can emphasize
the dopant atom.
Notice that the
inserted phosphorus atom
has five valence
electrons, four of which
form four covalent bonds with
their neighboring silicon atoms
and are immobile.
The fifth electron is not
bonded, and as a result,
is free to move
around the lattice.
When the negatively
charged electron leaves,
the phosphorus dopant is
now positively charged.
So we see that each
phosphorus atom that is added
will contribute a
single mobile electron.
So basically, in our case,
the number of mobile electrons
is roughly equal to the
number of phosphorus
atoms in our system.
Now, let's remove
our phosphorus atom
and put in an element with
three valence electrons,
such as boron.
We see here that boron lacks
the necessary valence electrons
to form covalent bonds to its
four neighboring silicon atoms.
This missing electron is
actually referred to as a hole,
and is represented
by an H+ symbol.
This hole acts as a
mobile positive charge
because it can swap places with
neighboring covalently bonded
electrons and move
around the crystal.
When the positively charged
hole leaves its nucleus,
the boron atom becomes
negatively charged.
So we've demonstrated
that introducing
atoms that have one more, or
one less, valence electron
than silicon, can
add mobile charges
and make the material
more conductive.
In our examples, the
conductivity of silicon
is proportional with the density
of either phosphorus or boron
atoms.
While phosphorus and boron
both affect the conductivity
in a very similar
manner, they introduce
mobile and static charges
of the opposite sign.
Phosphorus introduces
mobile negative charges
and immobile positive
charges, while boron
creates mobile positive charges
and immobile negative charges.
This subtle difference between
phosphorus and boron dopants
will be crucial
in our final video
when we discuss
solar cell operation.
Today we learned that
we can use doping
to control the conductivity
of semiconductors
by changing the number of
mobile charges in the material.
When we look at the
range of conductivities
that silicon possess,
it is truly amazing.
Through doping, we have
a very powerful way
of varying the conductivity
of semiconductors.
This is something that is
not possible in other classes
of materials, like metals.
Next time, we'll
be discussing how
light can be used to generate
mobile charges in silicon,
so watch our next video.
I'm Joe Sullivan, and
thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]